i want to give you a tip that i recently
learned that is literally transformed i
want everyone
after this is done to go out and do this
in your life because it is going to
change relationships for you you have
this goal
and if you were to write out all the
steps you would just be so overwhelmed
that you want to close it off but when
you start taking those teeny tiny steps
it's like oh yeah oh wait this is
necessary oh my gosh this is enjoyable
oh my gosh wait this is getting better
we have to stop
walking through life waiting for
permission the world needs more genetic
picture i i think so
hi buddy oh my goodness it's jenna
kitchen house my friend
how you doing
good look at how beautiful your back
lighting is i mean let's talk sets this
is amazing uh well you are the you know
former pro photographer i guess still
pro photographer but yeah this this uh
this came with the house so just got a
new house so i didn't this was not plain
i'm not smart enough you guys that's
amazing
speaking of things to be happy for
you get to unbox it i know i was so
excited when i saw that you were gonna
hold on to it until we were together
so this just came i mean we got the new
house and anyway so this just came like
you know what i'm gonna talk to her in a
couple days i'm gonna open it live
while we do this live on instagram and
youtube will get the repeat but you have
been on a crazy tour this came back from
new york city and it's been amazing your
face all over the business it's a trip
and not a vacation
um strong distinction we made it it was
amazing actually it was so much fun how
did you get these gold ups like it's
stamped ups i mean
this is awesome this is where the magic
is off
what does your mug say well i while i
work it says you need a budget so i have
been working out of this amazing
financial office in our small town in
minnesota yeah and this amazing female
entrepreneur was like if you ever need a
space for recording things just come on
down the street and so um i am using her
mug
there she is
i love it oh what's this
a necklace
i mean it would look really good on you
but i think i know someone who it might
look even better i'll put it on right
now this is it we lean into the we lean
into the awkwardness
ashley hines says which town am i in i
am in a small town outside of duluth
minnesota
well the first word here says believe so
that now i'm i have to put this on i
know
i am worthy
i love it i love it and then look at
this handwritten note
it's right up
i love it i go thank you you're welcome
thank you okay so while i while i work
out the necklace how are you really the
new book this is your first book ever
right it is it is it's so
unreal to like hold it in your hands as
i'm live right now tony robbins is
taking me in stories what is life right
now
um
it is so unreal you know the process of
how i don't know how to put this on it's
not going to fit over my hand
by yourself this is like a two-person
job no i can do this
there's a little clasp here okay
really how do you
women do they have to do this blind
right okay but i've never done this
can i i can wear it as like a headband
or something i mean i gotta take off my
ears right i believe in you okay hold on
i gotta take this off to be able to
breach under and make it happen um so
here here's what here's while i struggle
with this this is awesome i like lean
into the awkward here um
our mutual friend mel robbins yeah
told me that jealousy is a directional
signal so so whenever you're jealous of
somebody it means it's just an
inspiration that's that's blocked yeah
and so when i was thinking okay what am
i what am i jealous of jennifer you know
like she's got the book but like what am
i jealous of jennifer and the thing yeah
well the thing that came to mind was
you're so great at connecting with
people
you're really great
and when we first met in puerto rico
like two years ago three years ago three
years ago it's like i fell in love with
you and i didn't even know any i didn't
know who you were i don't listen to the
podcast so i knew who you were but it's
like man she's so warm and so kind and
so loving and so friendly and we're all
in this giant group chat with some of
the the biggest names in personal
development and entrepreneurship and
whenever you're recognizing people and
you're celebrating their wins and we
never have somebody when somebody has
something great to share yeah i always
feel awkward like i don't know what to
write so i was like
good job great
point and then jenna's like all emojis
and it's like i mean i don't know how to
so so
that
for someone who's maybe more awkward
yeah or introverted or shy like figuring
this stuff out what is your best advice
well i struggle to put this on yeah of
how to connect with people let's start i
want to give you a tip that i recently
learned that is literally transformed i
want everyone
after this is done to go out and do this
in your life because it is going to
change relationships for you
so um let me give a tiny bit of
backstory so i recently had my second
daughter quinn
and
for people that have children i feel
like there's two sides of the spectrum
half of the spectrum loves the newborn
phase half of the spectrum hates the
newborn phase it's one of those things
where it's like this crap shoot of like
whatever and it was so fascinating
because when i had my baby i would be
getting these text messages that were
polar opposites so some people would be
like oh my gosh aren't you just soaking
up every minute of it and then some of
them will be like just hold on it's all
temporary you're going to survive it and
i recognize that a lot of times when we
enter conversations we enter them with
our own context of what we think someone
should be feeling or experiencing and we
never actually give people the chance to
say
how are you really
and so i started doing this thing
with my friends and i want it to become
a movement is i want for people to reach
out to someone they love and say this
say
evan on a scale of one to ten where are
you at today so that i know how to show
up for you appropriately if you're a one
i'm going to cheer you on encourage you
give you that kick in the butt if you're
a 10 i want to celebrate with you i want
to just be with you and sit with you
and i think nowadays especially because
so much is so digital and we share so
much of our lives online it's like we
just assume that we know what's going on
in people's lives and how they are
really but when we enter conversations
and just say let me know where you're at
today and that way i'll show up for you
in the way that you need it the most it
absolutely transforms friendships so
evan where are you at today one to ten
um i'm just i'm mad you're struggling
i'm struggling
where is the where is the opening here
oh there you guys can you imagine if men
had to do the things that women have to
do honestly okay
oh siri just said that's not nice to me
that is amazing let's go siri siri
standing up for me come on get it come
on siri evan
they're saying
so let's see today i so i i think it
changes if i had to answer that question
honestly i had a really rough sleep like
the the ac was off for some reason your
chili pad wasn't working my chili pad
broke three days ago it broke yeah so i
have this chili pad that you put on that
like cools down the bed and yeah we were
talking about that that's fine yeah
and it broke and i love cool right like
cool so i was up i had a really rough
night but i wake up i gotta i'm working
on my new book and so i'm editing and
i'm going through it and i'm excited
like i'm tired but i'm excited and then
uh i see all the edits that my copy
editor came back with let's talk about
this like it's it's it's it's all it's
overwhelming at the start because
there's like about like 20 edits per
page yeah and like oh my gosh i do not
want to go through this document right
but like okay put on some music change
my state let's go i am like
killing my finger trying to
open this grasp holy cow
what do we think should evan give it up
no no no no no actually listen first off
this sweater is actually a woman's
sweater
because i wanted the the holes
men do not get thumb holes on their
hoodies that means i don't change that
needs to change i didn't even know i
went into the warehouse because i wanted
i love this i love the sound like the
deep hoodie like oh my god thumb holes
and i ordered a whole bunch and then
they then they told me after
uh that's a women's hoodie like whatever
i'm going with it yeah we're doing it so
i might as well go all in and get the
get the necklace going too so i see i
see the book with like a thousand edits
in there and i'm stressed out
overwhelmed and then you know what just
let's just start let's just start going
through them let's just start one by one
and most of them are things i don't even
care about it's like i missed a comma or
a semicolon instead of a whatever the
other thing is called like okay good
yeah yeah go use that i don't care
um
and so you forgot how life is though
where it's like if you have this goal
and if you were to write out all the
steps you would just be so overwhelmed
that you want to close it off but when
you start taking those teeny tiny steps
it's like oh yeah oh wait this is
necessary oh my gosh this is enjoyable
oh my gosh wait this is getting better
one of the things that i loved about the
writing process was the editing because
you love the editing oh my god i did
because i just felt like every version
got better
like where it was like every time i
handed it in i was like this is it i
know it's it and then it was like every
round of edits i was like oh no no this
is stronger this is stronger this is
stronger
yeah so i'm like
i wish i could reach through the screen
and do this for you
oh my goodness all right let's flip this
around here we go
evan is worthy everybody evan is i am
worthy i am worthy okay good we got our
change
it matches it matches the logo kind of
fits the decor perfect all right good
this is my new look for the day i love
it we're leaning in um anyway so like
for the how am i really so i woke up
like feeling a one and then started
getting to work and started feeling
better and then i saw how many edits i
had to do and then went back to feeling
like a one and i started working on it
and it was like oh this isn't bad i'm
back i'm like at a seven or eight then i
then we're gonna go live together like
oh i'm gonna ask jenna i don't know why
i am so now now i'm down to a three so i
go outside get some ground and spend
some time with my dogs watch the
interview you did because i normally
read the book but i haven't read this so
yeah like i watched the one you did with
tom and tom always ask great questions
like yeah okay i got a sense of where
we're going um
anyway so i think it bounces around
through the day now you're at ten now
we're ten cause i got the necklace all
figured out we're talking to jenna
kutcher we're making this happen this is
it
i love that isn't it crazy though too
there's actually a chapter on my book
that's titled feelings are meant to be
felt
and the reason is is that i think a lot
of times we're like moving through life
and it's like we think that we're just
going to wake up in a certain state and
that state is going to carry us through
the day but if you think about like your
emotional state your feelings your
emotions your energy like everything
it's like it's constantly changing and i
think as adults i've really learned this
especially as a mom
it's like with my three-year-old
it's like
a lot of times adults paint this picture
of like happiness is the goal of every
day like just if you're not happy get
there if you are happy stay there and
it's like a lot of times we're like
missing the full experience of life
because we're rushing through feelings
or we're not actually like sitting and
being like okay where am i at like why
am i feeling this way what is this
telling me what is the indicator here so
i think that's really cool too to bring
up like that you can be at a one and
then a ten and then a three and then a
five and you know what i mean it's like
we're bouncing around that's a human
experience
so you've had a crazy journey you know
going from like working at target and
being a limo driver and forklift
operator to then you know becoming a
photographer wedding photographer being
the best in the state for i think four
years in a row yeah and then launch
launching like an insane podcast that
takes over america to then
doing the book in 2022 to then 2023
being a youtube queen
[Music]
we're planting seeds we're planting some
seeds
jenna needs to be on youtube guys right
i know
you've always tried we'll get there
we'll get there it's happening momentum
is happening that's right but but those
are like some major
shifts yeah and and as i was
kind of researching the story and
watching the interviews is this so this
question of how are you really is this
just something that you use for other
people or was this also something
internal that helped create the shifts
yes okay that's such a great question um
so you know the difference in
conversation and i feel like you and i
have been at tables where we get past
the how are you and the accolades and
the good things and the fine and the
busy and the good and we get into the
like where we really at like even
recently when we were together in napa
and we were with all these leaders we
went around and usually people are
talking about business and like around
the table it was so much about life like
life was there's so much life happening
um
and when i think about like how are you
really
it's not only the question but it's like
the safe space to be like i trust that i
can handle the answers
or the responses or that the person that
is asking me the question is there to
like hold my truth
and
what i think is so fascinating about it
so the subtitle of the book is living
your truth one answer at a time
and it's not about and i love just i
just love holding it it feels like it
actually feels pretty amazing i don't
know what this cover is
but it's one answer at a time meaning
this isn't a question you ask yourself
once and you move on this is a part of
your life where you learn how to check
in with yourself where you learn how to
honor that question and trust your own
responses in it and also how to extend
the invitation for people i feel like
people these days are lonelier
more than ever like we are kind of
moving through life we've had to move
through life in silos for a long time
because of the pandemic and everything
and now it's like we're coming back out
and we're like who are my friends where
is the community who's going through
life with me like where is the village
and so i really think what's beautiful
about the question too is it's like when
we can start to get honest with
ourselves we can also invite other
people to get honest with themselves and
if there's a line in the book that it's
like in order to grow yourself you have
to know yourself and i feel like so many
of us are walking around and we don't
even know who we really are or what we
really want because we're just busy but
we feel like we're missing the point
every day we don't even know what the
point of the busyness is
you talk about the golden handcuffs that
keep people kind of stuck in their
business or stuck in their life or stuck
in a situation where maybe they don't
even like the thing that they're doing
but they're just it's security and
they're afraid to go to the to the next
step yeah is is this the question to ask
to get you out of the golden handcuffs i
think you already know the answer um
somebody messaged me this morning and
she said like the best compliment i
could receive about this book and she
sent me this long dm
and she said jenna i have to tell you
that i'm only 10 pages in and it's
insane because i can he finally hear my
own voice again like it feels like my
voice is shouting at me and i've been
ignoring it for so long
and um
part of the book and i don't want to
give it all away but one of the reasons
why i wrote the book was that somebody
looked me in the eye and they said to me
they said there's something you need to
do
and you know what it is
and i need you to go to do it and she
looked at me and she said do you know
what i'm talking about and immediately i
was like i have to write a book and it
was crazy because she didn't say i think
you need to write a book she said
there's something you need to do and you
already know what it is and so when you
think about things like the golden
handcuffs where it's like a lot of
people are staying in jobs because
companies are presenting all these
benefits and these flashy things and you
know first-class flying and the
ping-pong table and the break room and
all these things we're not even pausing
long enough to ask ourselves are those
benefits benefiting us like are they
actually adding value to us is this a
reason to stay in a spot that i know i
need to get out of
and so
this woman had sent me this super long
message and she was like i don't know
what to do and all i said back to her
was you already know what to do it's
inside of you you know
you're just waiting for me to like give
you permission but like we have to stop
walking through life waiting for
permission you know
i love it and you've
taken so many steps to live
so openly in terms of the content you
make and the vulnerabilities you're
sharing i mean that's partly why i think
people really gravitate towards you and
love you is that you you'll just even
before going live here it's like
yeah i gotta go feed the baby
i was like evan i'm gonna feed the baby
super fast but i gotta get her down for
a nap oh
so funny
so
but you know the the downside i guess of
that is there's a lot of judgment that
comes and especially if you're creating
content whether it's instagram or
podcasts or youtube videos and you
receive a lot of negativity and you've
certainly received your fair share
does it does it just get easier is there
a story you tell yourself does it still
sting just as hard for people who are
on the fence to like they know they're
not feeling well they got this thing i'm
going to write a book yeah but then
they're afraid of all the feedback and
criticism and the reviews how do we get
over it you know it's crazy evan
something that's been so shocking to me
somebody asked me what's been the most
surprising part of launching a book and
something that's been really unique to
me is um seeing like who shows up and i
mean this with like the most love in my
heart but like there are certain people
in our lives where you think that
they'll show up for you and they don't
and then there are people who you like
who come out of the woodwork and rally
and just support you and they believe in
you and it's been such an incredible
process and it's such a reminder for us
because i think there's so much fear in
changing or showing up as a new identity
because we're like this might make
someone in my life uncomfortable whether
it's your partner or your spouse or your
parents or your siblings or your friends
like
you worry about making other people
uncomfortable so you live in discomfort
and what's been so incredible about this
process is like people from like my
childhood people from working at the
paper mill people from target like
people that have been a part of my life
whether it was decades ago or days ago
are showing up with so much love and
support that it's like the people that
are meant to be there are gonna be there
and i've also recognized that
the fear in changing and making other
people uncomfortable keeps us stuck
when in reality the reason why people
closest to you sometimes have a hard
time supporting you is because they're
watching you change and grow and they're
still in the same spot it's more out of
their discomfort of you growing and them
staying the same
than the other way around and so when
you think about things like criticism or
lack of support that cannot be the
reason why you don't do what you're
called to do
like if you
dim your light or play small because of
those factors you are missing the
opportunity to impact people that are
meant to be impacted by you the people
that are waiting to rally around you and
so it has just been like such an
incredible experience because there are
certain people in my life who like i've
never felt closer to in the way that
they're showing up and then there are
certain people in my life where i'm like
hey maybe you don't get this but like
that's okay like i'm so excited about it
um and i won't shut up about it and so
that's just kind of like where you have
to land
well i think our brain will
automatically go to the negative right
so if somebody wants to launch a book
and you get 99 positive and one negative
comment you still hang on the negative
right always and and may not even be
people you know you're afraid of
some random person on instagram or
goodreads or youtube whatever so so how
do you overcome that is it does it still
hit you is that a mental exercise each
time it totally hits me you know what's
funny though evan there's a massive
difference that people don't understand
between criticism and feedback
and our world has gotten so convoluted
that we don't know how to separate those
two things and if somebody gives you
feedback that's incredible you have an
opportunity to learn and grow when i
wrote this book
in my head i had to keep telling myself
this is what i know so far
and what i mean by that is i'm 34. i
have a lot of life ahead of me these
pages are filled with what i've learned
so far what i know to be true for me and
my experience what i hope to be true for
everyone else but at the same point
there is an opportunity for growth
there's a chapter in the book that talks
about how like when we used to sign
yearbooks we would say like never change
and we would say that because there's
this fear of like if you change will we
still be friends if you change well we
still have things in common like if you
change will we still be connected and i
was like if we could go back and resign
all those yearbooks i would write i
can't wait to see who you become i can't
wait to watch you evolve and grow and
all of these things and so when we think
about things like criticism and feedback
if it's straight up criticism you have
to let it go you have to understand that
but if there's feedback in there how
cool is it that we as human beings get
to grow evolve change we get invited to
step into different spaces like
i actually love it i think it fuels me
because i'm like i love contradicting
myself i love changing i said i would
never write a book i also said i would
never be a mom
and so like i am living in these things
where i'm like look at me go look at me
grow look at me change like what a
beautiful invitation to be fully awake
to life and to really understand that
like we are students of life school and
so people are giving us feedback and
it's like actual feedback like how cool
is it that we get to grow and evolve i
don't know i think it's awesome the next
contradiction is getting jenna onto
youtube right and she said she's audio
only i've never said never on that one
you know what's funny evan is that like
so
i just have always hated being on camera
mostly because i like don't like putting
on makeup really when it comes down to
it and i just i've gotten so much more
comfortable i went live with mel robbins
yesterday and we were literally like
rolled out of bed like just texted each
other like hey screw 10 o'clock let's go
it's 8 30. and um and i was like that to
me is almost even more beautiful where
it's like so much more relatable but
maybe i'll get to youtube at some point
i'm i'm not opposed to it i'm not saying
never
it's the imperfect starts
jen is all about the imperfect i'm all
about those jenna in the closet making
her videos it's great i love it
okay what what the i mean i'll just
every time we connect you know i'll just
people just see what you think it can't
happen
the world needs more energetic picture i
i think so
what what does uh what does america need
to learn from small town minnesota oh my
gosh so much staying grounded
um why tater tot hot dishes a delicacy
um
why you should say the word sauna and
not sauna
um just kidding um all these things um
you know what i love is that and
a very big blessing in massive disguise
in terms of the pandemic is that i have
always operated my entire business and
career out of small towns when i founded
my photography business it was in a
village of 1200
when i launched my podcast it was in the
town of 10 000. like i live in a town of
10 000 right now
and
i love that we can connect like this
like to me
i always have wanted to just be able to
show up and connect
whatever that looks like wherever i am
in the world
um and so i just think it's really
beautiful because a lot of people have
excuses for why their dreams can't
happen and one of them always happens to
be where i live or that there's nobody
in my area doing these things
and i'm proof that that's not true but
i'm also proof that like you can do
massive things in small towns
and i wouldn't change it for the world
like i think that where i live and being
surrounded by my family keeps me so
grounded
that like no one cares about my work in
a way that makes it just feel like i get
a life and i get to work and i love the
work i do but i love my life even more
and that work helps fuel my life my life
does not revolve around my work even on
this launch week like i'm going to my
parents tomorrow to go in the pontoon
and like celebrate the 4th of july and
like there's nothing better to me
than building a business or building a
life that allows you to be like fully
awake to it and so i just feel like
being in a small town it's like so
beautiful because people don't make a
big deal about what i do in a way that
is so loving where it's just a part of
me it's not everything and i think in a
world
that is so fixated on titles and
importance and accolades it's so nice to
strip it down and just be a human like a
multi-passionate multi-faceted human
you've got a concept of uh find your
enough point right so like how much
money and every time i've heard you talk
about it in relation to money but does
it does it connect to other things as
well like
how much time you spend in la or new
york doing tours like is it is there an
enough point for you there before you
have to come home or oh yeah i mean it's
so funny so um we went to new york city
and drew my husband our two girls and my
mom all came with
and like it was the day after launch i
just done the today show we all went to
central park and i found myself riding a
merry-go-round on these horses with my
three and a half-year-old and it was
like the highlight of her trip
and to me it's like do the work
and then rest do the work and then enjoy
there has to be a cut-off point or else
you're just constantly on
and what i think happens and what i
think has happened is that like burnout
is everywhere right now
and um i was i was talking to mel about
this yesterday but i was listening to
this meditation and and in the
meditation it said
for all of us there was once a fire but
for many of us we feel like ashes
and we forget that like all it takes is
one ember one spark to get that fire
burning again
and i think a lot of us are burnt out
and so when we hear these messages that
say like pursue your passions we're like
i don't even know what i'm passionate
about like what is passion anymore i
literally just get up do my work go to
bed and do it all again the next day
like how do i figure out
how to move through life in a way that
doesn't just look good but that feels
good
and there's a line in the book that
talks about boundaries because i think
whenever you're talking about like
drawing a line in the sand saying like
this is enough there has to be
boundaries around it and so for me
there's a line that says boundaries
don't keep things people are
opportunities out of your life they keep
you in your life
and if i want to live a full life i have
to build boundaries around what is the
enough point in every area so that i am
in my life like i want to live fat
minutes meaning like i am here with you
now experiencing these next 60 seconds
of this minute so holy that i can close
my eyes eight hours from now and
remember right now and that's how i want
to move through life i don't want to
miss it
and so
when you think about having an enough
point there has to be this threshold
because what happens is and what leads
us to burnout is that we're setting
these goals and we're reaching them and
they feel empty and so we're tricking
ourselves into saying maybe that wasn't
enough maybe i just need to go a little
harder do a little more earn a little
more and then i'll finally be happy and
in reality it's like no no what if we
learned that contentedness doesn't equal
complacency and that when i'm content
i'm present and joyful and awake to my
life that's what i want the world to
know for real i love that i love that
all right last question um you've done
so much to pour into other people
i mean with the book with the with the
podcast everything you're doing and in
our in our group chat you're always
praying for people when they have
problems or issues or struggles so if if
people today
before they go to sleep were to pray for
you
for something they're going to hold you
on their heart what would you have them
pray for
okay this is a great question so i was
thinking about this this morning
with my book because when you work on
something for so long
if it's it's just this like outpouring
of you and you've been doing it behind
the scenes without people watching i i
liken it to watching a tree grow
nobody's gonna stick a chair outside and
watch a tree grow because it'd be boring
to see
but in reality underneath the surface
those roots are like lengthening and
strengthening and reaching and like
making that foundation stronger
and when i think about this book
it's this philosophy that people can
wake up to their life and to start
living a truthful life like a life that
truly feels good for them
and the prayer that i have is that
people don't just go through this
journey in the privacy of their own
heart but that they invite people into
this question
this book this philosophy with them
because
there's something so truly beautiful
when you can sit down with somebody and
say how are you really
and have them know with their heart of
hearts that you are there to hold them
whatever their response is whether it's
celebrating them
sitting with them waiting with them
praying with them and so i just pray
that it's not this journey that people
go on by themselves i hope that people
invite others into it with them because
i think it is going to give us this
richness of life and friendship and
community that we've all been craving
that we've all been desiring and it is
literally the invitation to hand it to
somebody and say i have space for you i
have capacity for you and i truly want
to know how are you really
the woman is jenna kutcher the book is
how are you really youtube we'll link it
up in the description below go check it
out jenna congrats on everything thank
you for the necklace yes you look so
handsome thank you for your friendship
evan i love being with you i can't wait
till we're together again and i'm just
so excited for your book and i can't
wait to walk you through this i feel
like i have learned so much in the
process and i was literally just telling
someone earlier i'm like can't wait to
like decompress all of these things and
walk people through this journey because
that's just how i am i just want to link
arms and take people on the ride with me
amazing thank you jenna appreciate you i
love you buddy see you later take care
to see my recent one-on-one with mel
robbins check the video right there next
to me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i hate
you evan i hope you lose evan i hope
your business goes bankrupt evan evan
you're a terrible person i spent the
first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else